[Music]
hello everyone thank you for joining
today so we're continuing the series of
webinars about Sparky are the first one
that I did was introducing Sparky are
and I mentioned that as I said some of
the different aspects of deploying
inside to talk about him today Xavier
did too in the middle which some that
felt a little bit under sequence and
that's because he wasn't going to be
able to make it today so I took this one
so if it's your side of sequence that
that's the reason why so I have in front
of you here
the different deployment modes and this
is essentially if we were to take the
deployment notes from the the Apache
website the official spark website here
so if I can go here and I go deploying
you'll notice the SS standalone meselson
yarn so you have these three this match
right here
you know mesos which is just a symbol
for medicine yarn and then the
standalone cluster so these are the two
sections right here that cover the the
ones that spark is talking about and
then we have the deployments based on
the articles from our website which
talks about local and cluster right so
this diagram here is meant to show
basically the two together like how how
can we work with with Sparky our and
spark and in both of the deployment
modes so the first one is talked about a
managed cluster rat is either managed
through yarn which is the most common
and then managed termessos usually
whenever you have a managed cluster that
means that the resources are being
managed centrally
and that you have a master note and then
some slave nodes in the cluster whenever
we talk about adding our and sparkly art
to the cluster usually means that we're
going to add it to one of the notes
usually like an edge note right so you
don't have to have our and every single
package and style and every single note
that's one of the big advantage just
feel sparkly are is because it's very
great approach which I talked about in
the first webinar and simple approach
allows it to not have to be you know
running in every single note same thing
for standalone cluster you'll notice
that it's not a managed network and that
means that there's not a service that
coordinates everything what it is is
there's an actual machine that's called
the master node that is the one that
coordinates all the work so usually you
can install the R and Sparky are in one
of the other notes but also you can
style in the master node and I've done
that both ways usually the end are put
in the master node myself just because
the master now it doesn't give any
resources once you are open the new
spark connection this pendulum cluster
is actually really useful whenever you
want to basically get your feet wet with
an actual spark implementation if you
want to try it out and you don't want to
build an entire data lake you know you
can actually do some build something
like this in in the cloud you know like
with AWS you can set up a few boxes if
you what they call ec2 instances which
is their virtual servers and connect
them just like if they were physical and
we actually have instructions about that
in our website as well if I go to spark
arrestor EUCOM and I have the link in
the back so but I just want to show you
on your deployment Amazon
MSNBC - the reason why I'm showing you
this is because I recently updated it to
do then I'll show you the instructions
on how to do a more recent version of
spark in this case this would be spark
2.0 1.0 so that this set of instructions
is again if you want to start kind of
trying it out I'm sorry
turn it out you would be able to allow
to do that with standalone again most
common is yarn just because usually you
have a business that has a data lake but
standalone I've seen several deployments
in companies and that's because they
have they have existing grid computers
that they want to start using with spark
so they're able to kind of do that
switch over and then they're able to
process the data so one of the questions
is of course worst versus the data
coming from you know in okay so in yarn
you know you have the data and their
data like inside the Hadoop cluster but
in standalone it needs to be in just as
somehow we'll talk about that in a
minute
also you notice this remote cluster but
really managed cluster it will be
another way of connecting I actually
consider put in this graph right here
because that would be like more
appropriate in a sense but they felt
very cluttered a you know very hard to
read so just think the remote cluster
managed cluster both in yarn and the
idea here is that this a lot of cases
where you cannot install our and sparkly
are in one of the edge nodes for
whatever reason you know the separation
of duties between 90 and the data
science team or it's just that the
clusters would lock down you can't
really do it then
livvie would be a good option and xavier
talked about that in his videos webinar
so i just wanted to bring that out that
there is another way of connecting I've
heard of a few companies that actually
doing that just keep in mind that yeah
our support for Livi is definitely much
improved since version 5
but I think you will have to do a good
review of how this service works because
you had to start a service a little
service instead inside the cluster so
your remote users can connect and
there's some considerations about
security and also about data movement
that you may want to consider especially
if you're an architect as well that does
satisfy both there's performance needs
and security needs of your teams and of
course local which is like I mentioned
and it's part comm site we are we have
local and remote and cluster excuse me
so local is really cool and this is what
I used in the first webinar which is
that well you can actually start a spark
environment inside your laptop and be
able to do all sorts of things just to
try it out
and be able to see how it works if you
recall hopefully you were in that first
one I was able to switch over and see
how the memory was being managed and
show the UI and all that stuff so is
really nice to do that also it works in
other environments or opera insistence
that it's not Linux so all this would be
in a Linux environment except this so
local the way that Sparky are was
written is that it can also run in
Windows machines and Mac and I'm running
on a Mac and I did that demo so this is
a very good way of getting started
another thing that I noticed that you
can do is Berkeley are on the local mode
or those not prescribed thing to do is
if you want to do use multiple cores for
an analysis that's something that you
actually can do it with with your spark
environment I actually found that
reading in data with a sparkler
connection on that file that is larger
than one gigabyte is actually faster
Sparky are so it was pretty nice to test
out you know if you want to if you're
curious about that and you definitely
recommend trying starting a local
environment with your in your laptop all
right so recently we included when I say
we I mean
included spark apply function
this does change the paradigm a little
bit where we usually say like I will
send here you need to stop are in every
single note in this case you would if
you want to do spark apply so it you
don't have to have every library
installed that's something that the
spark apply command will help you do but
you do need to have are in the notes
that you run in against so this is
another consideration that I think needs
to be said that you don't have to have
our and every single note if you're not
going to use spark apply but if you do
that changes the architecture a little
bit if you're a data scientist that is
trying to you know find the easiest way
to move your are code into and scale it
up this may be a good way at least it
looks at first but just know that the
code that you're running in in here we
have to be highly paralyzed so the good
way of thinking about this is if I have
a Massiah model that I want to run I
want to fit against all the customers in
my database right so when I run a linear
regression a single linear regression
against each individual customer then
this model may work really well for you
because what it's doing is that it's
going to take each of those customers is
going to run the model in each worker
node and so it's going to separate the
job that way but let's say now if I were
to have a really large job let's say I
want to run the same model over all my
customer activity regardless of who the
customer are then there's no good way of
paralyzing it and that's where that may
not be the best choice to do this part
apply or at least this way in maybe
better to consider a native you know
spark machine learning library or maybe
an extension like h2o extension for
example so I just want to mention that
as you start you
since markiplier getting acquainted with
it that that that would be a good way of
kind of know if you can switch or not so
let me go here something that I found
and speaking with some folks who are
getting into spark or getting into into
are we have you know Enterprise
architects this give us a call to
understand all the stuff and hopefully I
see there's a certain ease so if you if
you're an are user that's getting to
spark hopefully you'll see some of the
stuff today so new concepts
it is me very early on in your spark you
know career so I want to do some
concepts and if you're more on the
architecture side if you're in the big
data environment already hopefully some
of the stuff I'll show you that will be
also new to you that you can see how it
can be used for data analytics these
from their perspective so real quick
spark concept so we have a dragger a
master a worker and an executor
so just to to clarify sometimes the
executor and the we say executor it gets
confused with a worker or sometimes we
hear the turbo driver and it's kind of
hard to separate although because it's
not the same terms that we use in group
so a driver is essentially the drive the
program that starts the Despard context
so that would be spark we are in our
case right and usually the machine or
the server the start step program is
considered a driver note then the master
would be whomever is managing the spark
job which is it could be like mentioned
either machine itself a server or a
service right like yarn and then a
worker is essentially the the machines
where you can actually do the heavy
lifting right it's going to do the
calculations but where it gets tricky is
the fact that
each worker will not handle only one job
you can actually have multiple jobs
running inside the same worker because
how smart works is that splits the work
amongst executors so you can technically
have more than one executor inside a
worker and that is very important to
know and to keep in mind because that
goes back to how we do those deployments
and when I say deployment I'm actually
also using higher term which is not only
deploying new environment but also
deploying at the point analysis and and
deploying a new connection to to spark
another thing that is important to to
keep in mind is how we do data load with
sparkly are so at the end of the day
goes down to two options that we have
the first option is to essentially tell
spark we are where the data is right so
we tell spark hey the data is in this
high table go ahead and encash it right
so when it catches it it never goes
through my our environment it goes
directly into the spark cluster and then
I tell you Sparkle you are to see the
data in there I can also tell hey my
data is in this s3 bucket go get it then
this part can go and get it through a
package spark package to be able to know
how to read those two data and bring the
data in again it doesn't go to our so
this is the best approach to have when
we are using using spark to bring a
large data sets because and what we
found this that a lot of new users will
try to do option to you right off the
bat which is that you can notice that
the data is first and then you so put it
in this case you have a bunch of data
that we load into our our environment
and then try to push that into the
cluster
this works really good in fact we're
going to see that today but for smaller
datasets you see you want this option to
you won't need to use it for you know
look-up tables that to enrich the data
that you the main data set that you
already have in spark this option to
should be the last option that that you
should take option one should be always
the first thing that you want to look at
you want to make sure that the data
isn't spark ingest the data now that our
interests the data this like I said not
knocking down option two because it's
very useful like I said to bring in more
information more maida information about
your data but shouldn't be your first
choice two things that spark needs to
read the data obviously access to the
data and the second is a parser so it
needs to know how to read
you know redshift databases how to read
CSV file sorry hi
data you know how to read s3 bucket so
all that different parsers are usually
handled via the package right and when I
say access to data I'm going to switch
back to this one right here so when I
say access to data means that every node
in that cluster needs access to that
data this means and which is kind of
tricky because sometimes we may have a
file that we bring into this node but
this two nodes cannot see the file right
so when we try to load it into memory
won't work because they can't they don't
have the same path to the file I have in
there and the file introduced or
uploaded to the OneNote so that's why I
mentioned here that for standalone mode
especially you know it's simple
approaches to create a network share so
if you want to do you know a simple file
that you want to we have you know spark
read into memory without having to have
an s3 bucket or if you don't have a data
Lake then just use a simple network
share and after
that the Samba share you know it's you
make this it makes the same calf a
relative path the same amongst all the
circlet nuts in the cluster and you're
able to ingest your data oops right so
let me so I have some reference things
here we just released this new article
and I'm going to talk to it here in a
second and also we have the standalone
deferment in AWS which is the one I
mentioned that if you want to start
getting acquainted with the deployment
modes and also this one which I'll be
updating by the end of next this one
yeah next month so some of the stuff I'm
gonna do may be a little bit different
then when you see in this article and
that's because I'm I need to update it
but the main concepts are there about
how to use s3 data with would spark so
let's go to the demo here okay so I'm
running right now in a Hadoop cluster
Ladera cluster that has yes essentially
four nodes writes and my my name right
here and in that cluster I have I say a
physical details you know so on AWS is
not really physical but it's for worker
nodes they have 15 gigabytes of RAM each
have four cores so obviously we have the
total 16 cores 60 gets around available
it's just a very small cluster but
hopefully you'll see some of the
examples here and how that would apply
to your cluster but there's two or three
settings here the two main ones are yarn
and node manager
we are resource memory and resource CPU
be course these are the two that may
need to be updated in your manager you
know whatever system used to manage in
this case
manager you can make those changes in
the actual setup so this may be
something that you need to work with
your big data administrator and I talked
about that in that article here
the deployment connections article
that's mentioned here and I'll show you
a poster because usually there's an
error that occurs that the the default
is set pretty low like 8 gigabytes for
executor so if you ask for 92 bytes
you'll see this error and you know just
you right there to go look at that at
those settings and these settings that
cannot be set in the configuration that
we do here those settings can only be
changed in the manager here or directly
in the XML file for 4-yard so that's
that's something very important to keep
in mind so you can do the configuration
changes by updating the sparkle shake so
you make a copy of that and they made
some of the changes so one of the things
that I mention here is that for your
user configuration start small and just
build slightly bigger so I've seen some
configurations I'm gonna say that I mean
these configurations that essentially
look like like this like 20 lines before
you even get to the connection and it
makes all sorts of changes it's instant
making no sense of what what is being
requested so that that is ok if for
whatever reason that's not your
environment needs proof you a new user
that just trying to get some more you
knows performance out of your connection
just start smoke right in this case
we'll just have executor memory secular
course instances and the dynamic
allocation the same ones that are being
proposed here and their article so you
can always go back to here and I can
connect so
notice that we're not gonna hear and I'm
all I'm doing some requesting one
gigabyte per executor one executor poor
and you need ten instances so because
I'm honored my threshold obviously of
the 32 gigabytes I'm gonna expect it to
give me ten instances because I have
definitely more than ten course and
that's what we're gonna I'm gonna expect
to see that return so we go to Hue I got
one job running chap number 26 take a
plane sir so I'm able to see what to see
this so you'll notice that I've got my
ten executors right and each one is
giving me I definitely like half of what
I requested the memory that's because of
the overhead that is taking from my
session my requested session and it's
also but it does give me all the
executors that I asked for right so very
important to see going back to the point
about that one note can have multiple
executors so this is a worker note see
this it has the same IP address but it
it has two different ports right and
these are the ports to the actual
executors so here you can see that
there's two executives in the same
machine so they're gonna act as if there
were their own little like virtual
machines but they're really both inside
the same box this is important to also
note that the there's a balancing act
that has to take place between how much
resources you're giving each executor
and how many executors you have
because in this case is where this is a
very small cluster again but when we
talk about with larger clusters the
certain best practices that you need to
approach it you should use to approach
it so I would definitely recommend you
going through to this article I have a
link to a nice Ladera article with a
discuss on that and the next thing how
the the resources are given and some of
the best practices are talking about
here so I would I would definitely go
back to that but note note that we got
the resources that we wanted here so I'm
going to now send over just spark lights
so have a flag stable that's already in
my cluster so let me show you that's
it's already there so I only have one
hive table that shows up here and I just
made a pointer to it but so this the
flights spark it's just a pointer to the
table and then I can do you know just a
straight count
and it shows me that we have 42 million
records in there so since several years
of that flights data that was a job that
brand in the cluster here so you can see
the jobs so then for seconds
usually that takes a lot longer but
because we're using a metric cluster a
lot faster and I can do Kampai by unique
carrier it's a little bit longer but you
can see a job running here okay so I'm
gonna disconnect here another thing that
I wanted to suggest is like it mentions
here we need to give dynamic allocation
chance so dynamic allocation is also
mentioned an article it's it's a way
that yarn can give you the researchers
work that you need on the man right so
if you're working on a cluster that
other people using as well then you may
want to consider this that way yarn can
decide to add or remove resources for
your spark connectionists as needed and
all you have to do to get it is
essentially don't put in a configuration
this is native to our yarn
implementation so you'll see let me go
to that would be 28 now this new job
executives notice that I have no
executives which is very inner being
especially the first time I used it
because I'm so used to seeing my
executives already listed and when
they're not listed you know something's
wrong right so here I can go ahead and
we're gonna catch the entire flight
stable and then I'm gonna equate it to
this variable so when I cash it it
should start using resources from the
executors
so you see there all the sudden
we have active tests so it automatically
started creating the executives for me
we create a bunch of calm trying to get
all of my all of my tests done so it was
able to do the job in basically 23
seconds I got I got my Flags table
cashed and of course this is going to
run a lot faster once it's in memory
right so you saw how the executives just
missed we started appearing
automatically which is great you know
especially if like I said if you share
in this server this is the cluster and
also if you need to spark the you can
start without any settings and in a day
delay for using yarn client and I would
say that should be like the first thing
you should try
since we're connected I'm gonna talk
about going back to the deployment and
reading data so we have the two things
right now we told little spark to go get
the data from hive and load it into
memory
the other thing that we can do is to get
it to read data from together to read
the data from the our local machine
right over there so let me show you here
so it says spark read CSV we want to
read the plain CSV file right which is
right here so if I run this I actually
expect enough to work so I'm gonna run
there and see it fail and the reason is
tails is because bar read CSV is not
reading against your home directory in
our it's actually reading against your
cluster so you'll notice that if I were
to show you in Hue my files here
I don't have planes that CSV I have an
airport CSV and we're gonna use that in
a minute but not a plane's dot CSV right
so if I want to get planes into into my
spark environment I essentially have two
options right I either take the plane's
PSD file and use hue or something to
upload it to my cluster or I do what
we've talked about an option to
essentially load it into our memory and
then put it in sparked which is what I'm
doing here so I'm going to read it into
memory using Vidar and then I'm going to
use copy to to send it over to my
environment now that it's an environment
now I can do a joint and works just like
a regular deep layer or sequel I would
like to see it but now I'm able to do
something like this wreck and in the
planes that have manufacture so I can do
how many flights per manufacturer so now
I combine the two tables in there you
saw that I know that for me to do that I
have to send it over using this option
and as pro we can tell is not best
actually if this bar will be huge that's
that's why if this table would have been
in my opinion over one gigabyte I would
have used queue and just upload it here
and it read it out of the HDFS which
we're gonna do here in a minute okay so
moving on another cool thing that I want
to show you is same here so we were
using hive and of course that is big
part of yarn so in its far in Hadoop
they're all these very relay
interconnected technologies so I wanted
to do something remote so we're gonna do
s3 so I'm gonna load my access key for
s3 which is that article I was talking
about AWS with s3 and then I'm going to
wanna stop this for now
I'm not going that start and you
configure
something that request for course
actually chance justified so five
gigabytes should give me 20 gigabytes
and for country right and for course
their each give me entire set up and
this is the important piece that the
default packages is what I tell spark
what package to use during its while
it's running and in this case this
Hadoop AWS is the one that we need to
run to for it to be able to parse st
bucket files so I opened the connection
and that should created anyone here
Junko 16 course I'm 17 your bike's
sometime and that's my spot
okay and now this is really cool so I
can tell the path on a spirit is start
with CSV
I'm telling spark to go to this path and
this timer here is 3/8 flex data foo is
this right here so I have an s3 bucket
in this full folder I have these CSV
files right and see how big they are so
what I'm gonna do is some point in the
pointing spark to where the data source
is and I'm telling it to go ahead and
don't bring it into memory yet
don't further scheme I'm gonna give you
what the schema is and just go ahead and
essentially map it so that's what my
circulars are gonna do to start you see
that was a very nice job it's just yeah
this be going over to s3 and confirming
though that what I'm telling it is there
and now oh and another thing I also
mentioned that in the first webinar you
notice that I don't put the file names
here I'm just putting a path right and
what the trick here is that every single
file in here has the same layout so it's
being used just like it would be in hive
if you're related to if you are aware of
how it works inside that you have
multiple files but all of them can have
should have the same layout so they will
consider one big file so the next thing
we're gonna do is I'm gonna cash some of
the data and I'm using compute so now I
can see in storage as the data gets
cached
she is crushing and now we're gonna used
to stay there once it's fully cached
we're gonna go and do some more work
with it so hopefully you see that I'm
talking about both type of load data and
how to do some tuning to better deploy
you know many environments but also your
user configurations so they can be tuned
in a better way okay
so now we're gonna use sparks yes there
are spark beats CSV to get the airport's
dot CSV file which is the other file I
have idea the father I have here so that
that is an HDFS so I'm able to say get
from there just going to go directly
into my my spark contacts from there I
can join it
and now I can do some analysis with it I
think I'd like to top busiest airports
but now we have the name since they
register the code another thing that I
was nice to him the airport's file is
the longitude latitude right and since
unable to join it to the large 42
million record table then I can do this
I can take the demurrer the John's table
and then get longitude latitude and name
and group it by it get how many flights
happen and then get me the top 1,000 so
this is the top 1,000 airports and how
many flights there are are
but it still I'm going to bless the cat
and then I have here I can run a
visualization for example so I can map
them because there's so many you'll see
that it actually shows your shape of the
u.s. already and and what I did is I had
the colors in as well as the size so
it's very easy to see what lanta is
where Houston is Chicago you know so you
see really easy to visualize and I used
to have to collect to get the data back
into the our memory and it's until now
we have some data as a data set but you
see that we're not getting anything
anywhere near to what we would the
amount of data that we're working with
inside our last thing I want to show you
is this new package I've been working on
called DB plot there's a new thing that
new feature of it where you can actually
run a box plot so that you can
definitely do it manually and you can
look at the code if you like but it's
really nice because actually box plots
are they paralyze so run much faster
then then it would if we were to bring
the data back into memory so what I did
here is I took the top list
which represent I think like at least
50% so maybe 20 million records and I'm
doing a box flop over the DOS top 20 and
then the distance so he saw that ran
pretty fast and all I had to do was to
call do a box plot so maybe something
that you want to consider looking at on
the I just made a change recently
preferred to support older versions of
height so if he tried it before and they
didn't work just know that it does work
now have a quick appendix down here that
talks about reading and you have table
which is how I actually got the hive
store loaded with the flight's table
here so something does that we don't
talk about much is this function right
here spark right table if you're working
on a spark and Hadoop cluster managed by
yarn and if you want to persist data
because you're not as soon as I close my
connection here but it is gone right and
I'm sure some folks ask questions about
ok but what if I want to keep the data
you know usually you would plant create
a large file and put an HDFS and then
something else with it but normally what
we want to do is to go back and analyze
it later
you can do spark right table and take
the the spark data frame and then give
it a name and that's the name that that
ended up here and what it does in the
background
it creates not only the the the actual
you know mapping and all that but also
does the partitions for us so it creates
a bunch of smaller per K files and saves
them into the end to the warehouse
folder so a really nice function I don't
think we talked about it too much but if
you're in a your environment this book
doesn't be of advantage so I'll show you
just this is two standalone cluster so I
did the same thing and this was going to
be part of the original demo but I do
want to show you real quick here the
standalone cluster and if I were to do a
connection here so I'm going to in a
spark stand-alone to go to the actual
you know location with your job is
because there's only one job from from
the driver you can just switch from the
same URL but to port 80 88 - give me
four 40 sorry and then we
show you here older the jobs and I can
show you here that secular page
something about the secular page is that
the course will always be managed by the
master and we always have be running how
many actual servers you have so it's
very rare but we're going to need more
than one you know
executor per per note and it's kind of
hard to to set it up unless you start
manipulating the dynamic allocation and
the number of course to be lower than
what's available in in the server in the
in the worker node so again you've
noticed that all these are the same
except the memory fraction you actually
have control over that so I'm gonna
close this real quick and we open it so
memory fraction will actually give me
closer to the seven gigabytes it doesn't
set in up to ninety percent and if I go
back here you see it gives me 35
gigabytes which is I said gimme two so
I'm gonna reopen it here and I'm gonna
say en i-94 my percent what I'm asking
for this in order to change this to 30
percent for example
here you notice that now it's much lower
that's because the faction is something
that you can control it's a big point
that if you're going to be doing some
stand alone it's also mentioned in the
article it's considered moving the
memory extraction a little bit too if
you need more space in your in your
cluster so just to then do a quick
review I'm gonna go back to here if you
have a this is a community atom for
today if you had data load options and
questions definitely think about these
two options right and always try to load
the data from the remote source directly
into spark in and always consider the
option to to be more about just for
smaller tables as well as last resort is
even not all this the nodes have access
to the same data source so that's all I
have man thank you we have a new door
that's open to us with Sparky our estate
analysts the way that sparked their
approach this has helped us to be able
to use what we are in a very effective
way and do the thing that tells me is
the fact that we having webinars and
really promoting it and also developing
it is just supposed to show that our
commitment to to make it even better for
everyone that that I think that says a
lot as well so I know that natively but
spark really only works with hive so
there may be a way to get some HBase
connectivity but I haven't worked with
it myself that that's something that is
interesting for us to to look at we also
have a separate effort to start doing
more support of different data sources
directly into our through the data
connections tab that is you notice that
there's no spark anymore
and HBase is one of the ones that we're
going to
so I'm sure we're going to have some
documentation about that here soon
[Music]